de nature à contenter des attentes des
réunionnais en termes de lutte contre la
pauvreté et le chômage voilà pour
l'impression globale qui ressort après
le passage de maquereaux nous
demanderons notre invité s'il fait la
même analyse ce qu'il retient lui du
voyage présidentiel en invité députés
qu'ils communiqueraient qu'elles sont
santé d'éducation de formation le
développement économique son travail à
l'assemblée nationale porte-t-il ses
fruits comment voit-il les prochaines
élections municipales dans le contexte
de la division de la droite reynès et
david lorion le député républicain
conseiller municipal de saint pierre qui
sera l'invité de lundi pour litiges sur
la première dans quelques minutes le
temps d'arriver
[Musique]
cheveux des problèmes
je veux que tes galère deviennent les
miennes
je veux que tu balances au visage des
orages des peines pour déni du lui
revient
jme contre après je veux partager des
joies des immigrés sont comme dans le
vertige et emma même pour rien
je pourrais monte à tous et notre
histoire sur le bras me met dans de
beaux draps cité avec moi c'est toi dans
ce monde de fous je ne sais c'est tout
je voudrais que ça dure longtemps usé
m'approcher la tienne un jour
j'oublierai tout jusqu'à mon nom je
saurai simplement que tu es là que tu es
belle que tu es mienne je voudrais que
ça dure s'entend
jamais la rissole atteignent cet aveu
cette envie de rêver tous les deux quand
même jusqu'à ce qu'un jour nous deux
yeux c'était
[Musique]
mon évidence tu es mon sourire et ma
carte chance je veux qu'on des cons
d'école qu'on délire comptant ce
jusqu'au dernier silence
[Musique]
j'irai dans la réussite un besoin de
soin je pourrais vivre nu et porter un
pour moi
froid c'est toi dans ce monde de fous
je le sais c'est tout
et je voudrais que ça dure longtemps
usée mapuche tienne
un jour je n'oublierai tout jusqu'à mon
jeu sort est simplement que tu es là que
tu es belle que témoin
je voudrais que ça dure
que cela me désole c'est un peu cette
envie de rue
tous les deux camps mais jusqu'à ce
qu'un jour nos deux yeux c'était
[Musique]
je voudrais que ça dure longtemps usé
map aussi tiennent un jour j'oublierai
tout jusqu'à mon nom je sors et
simplement que tu es là que tu es belle
cote énième je voudrais que ça dure
sentant
que ce soit même
devehat tant fait rêver
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour l'on désire
c'était
m
[Musique]
lundi politique peut démarrer avec
quelques minutes entre nous excuser
david lorion député michel sordi
politique sur la première jusqu'à 13
heures vous pourrez poser vos questions
à face à 12h45 au 02 72 99 2000
d'ailleurs le bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans l'actualité il ya
l'arrivée triomphale ce matin johnson 12
ans qui a remporté l'émission vos cils
sur tf1 après avoir remporté qui
crachent sur la première fois la
première on le rappelle je deviendrai
miss international c'est finalement de
façon pour la réunion d'exister pour
nationale peut-être plus qu'à travers
une visite présidentielle quel regard
vous portez vous sur cette actualité
people mais qui dealent s'ils bougent
peut-être du mouzon de reconnaissance
d'abord c'est la naissance d'une étoile
avec une voix cristalline envoûtante la
fierté très certainement de son père de
sa mère de tous ses parents évidemment
la fierté de tous les spectateurs qui
ont entendu qu'ils ont vu soan chanteurs
comme on dit assez sinon ça fait du
baume au coeur et puis ça ça permet à
tous et à tous les enfants qui chantent
tous les artistes qui se produisent se
dire que c'est possible atteint des
sommets il faut les encourager
on va revenir en détails sur les
différentes informations du voyage
présidentiel celui là après finalement
fait moins deux mois aéroport en tout
cas dans les grands livres
qu'est-ce que vous aurez
grandes lignes présidentiel à libreville
on ne s'attendait pas à une disruption
très importante et on n'a pas eu non
plus on a eu une politique qui a été une
politique réaliste qui prolonge ou qui
complète les mesures ou des réformes qui
était déjà enclenchée
ce n'est pas le grand soir 1 la visite
du président macron c'était une visite
très réaliste est vraiment à ses fins
avec une certaine déception évidemment
déception parce que parce qu'il y avait
trop d'attenté parce que les on s'était
pas gêné jamais trop d'attentes les
attentes parce que ça va mal aujourd'hui
j'ai dit à l'assemblée la croissance
décroche en 2018 on me dit c'est ton
était à 3% de croissance à 1,7
les voyants sont au rouge en terme de
chômage pour les jeunes pour les
familles il ya beaucoup de coupes
sombres entre 1 m 1 dans tout ce qui a
été fait sur le plan social aujourd'hui
la population souffre et il ya des
attentes à cause de ça et donc
aujourd'hui on s'attendait plutôt
certains d'entre nous s'attendaient
plutôt à propositions des lois au g avec
un certain nombre de mesures très fortes
en termes de mesures pour la jeunesse
notamment d'accompagnement et des
bourses qui sont plus élevés pour les
jeunes qui confère les études qui vont
se former 10 aides aux entreprises qui
vont un peu plus loin que ce qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui avec des aides pour la
production agricole en se disant ce sont
les aides qui vont donner un élan
nouveau en fête à l'économie reynès
on a eu des mesures fait dire qu'il
s'est bien passé le président a fait
quelques réformes mais on voit
évidemment tous que ce ne sera pas
suffisant à faire changer les choses
évidemment demain unis la confection sur
le terrain un type de la lutte contre
contre joiret soupe ce plan pétrels cg20
action pour l'emploi avec 700 millions
d'euros avec un dispositif emploi
réunion qui sera très partir du 1er
janvier pour les personnes qui habitent
dans les secteurs dans le quartier
politique de la ville
avec donc des les emplois francs c'est à
dire faire des choses pour les niçois
qui sont difficiles avec des aides
directes aussi pour les employeurs ça
c'est une ça c'est une bonne mesure
c'est quelque chose qu'on était dans le
tuyau qui est juste confirmé mais on est
à voir au logis il ya eu des annonces
très concrètes notamment il ya des
annonces de prolongement des becs sur
ceux sur cet aspect là je ne s'étant pas
feront dans les secteurs secteur
géographique
alors est-ce que c'est ce que c'est une
d'abord les emplois france c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau insister assez
longtemps un cellier en fait à la
politique de la ville aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que c'est quand même pas franc pour
tout le monde comprenne bien
c'est la possibilité donnée à une
entreprise d'avoir une subvention de
5000 euros en trois ans sinon pour un
jeune en cdi et est à moitié après six
ans pour un jeune en cdd pendant au
moins six mois
donc c'est un avantage les hauts
quartiers prioritaires de la réunion ce
qui représente à peu près en chie
convient un quart de la population
donc c'est une mesure il était dans ces
secteurs qu'il ya le plus de difficultés
alors ce sont dans ces secteurs où il ya
le plus de difficultés mais ce n'est pas
une mesure qui a donné un emploi très
important en réalité même en métropole
c'est une mesure assez limité parce que
y'a une problème de formation et
problème d'inadéquation parfois entre
les besoins d'entreprises et les besoins
du jeune et puis ça ne répond pas à
quelque chose d'important se dire qu'on
jeunes qui ont réussi dans ces quartiers
leur offre pas non plus la possibilité
d'occuper un poste de management les
postes de direction et parfois vous
voyez que ces mesures sont bonnes pour
l'entreprise mais ne correspond pas
exactement ce qu'attend les jeunes dans
ces quartiers où s'étendent les jeunes
formés de ces quartiers
oui très bon ni au besoin dans les moins
formés parce que je n'y a pas les
passions traiteront des entreprises et
etzella ni au mieux formés parce que son
corps dit oui en réalité ce qu'attendent
les jeunes qui sont les moins formés
c'est que le temps l'information et
puissent vivre
lorsqu'un jeune sort du bac à dans un
lycée professionnel ou en lycée général
je les accueille des fois l'université
n'ont pas les moyens de faire a dit
venir des frais viennent ils ont les
difficultés ils arrêtent leurs études
parce que les forêts réunionnaises qui
sont à 40% en dessous du seuil de la
pauvreté
non pas tout les moyens d'en faire les
études supérieures de se former et donc
il est nécessaire et qui est de
rencontrer le président a bien dit il
est nécessaire de mieux accompagner les
jeunes qui vont faire les formations
j'ai dit au moment de mon programme
lorsque je suis présenté en tant que
député il ya une nécessité d'adapter les
indemnités qu'on donne jeunes on se
former que ce soit formé railhawks
formant ni trop molle pour que le
maximum de jeunes puissent aller le plus
loin aussi dans la formation mais ça
nécessite un accompagnement plus
important que celui qui existe en
métropole
d'une part parce que ça coûte plus cher
parce qu'il pense qu'il faut à la
métropole et celle d'autre part parce
que les parents sont les unes sont dans
une une difficulté sociale plus
importantes qu'en métropole et donc on
attendait sur les jeunes à
l'accompagnement beaucoup plus fort que
ce qui a été aujourd'hui met en place ce
départ devant simplement de l'argent aux
entreprises qu'on crée cette dynamique
ces jeunes sans l'accompagnement
directement les jeunes d'autre part les
jeunes qui sont déjà formés le président
a dit dans une phrase tout à fait si
céline qu'on va flécher quelques postes
évidemment dans son parler d'eux
réfléchir à beaucoup de jeunes mais qui
sont aujourd'hui formés
il faut leur dire à un moment donné
qu'il y aura une politique non pas
spécialement des préférences régionales
une politique d'accompagnement de tous
ces jeunes rennais former pour qu'ils
occupent des postes de responsabilité
que ce soit l'administration où que ce
soit dans les entreprises il faut mieux
les accompagner pour ça c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui est-ce que le volet
formation de deux ans contre près pour
voir ça parce qu'on a montré par école
aussi de quelques depuis leurs dizaines
de milliers d'informations en accord
avec la région où est-ce qu'on en dise
aussi est-ce que ça peut répondre à
cette faille au général je vais vous
dire et j'ai dû déjà une ou deux fois
pendant les vingt ans qui se sont
passées on a sans doute trop misé sur
des investissements en infrastructures
lourdes et peut-être pas assez sur la
formation des jeunes aujourd'hui la
situation avec un taux d'illettrisme
très important et qu'une difficulté
évidemment chez les jeunes dans le cas
de la formation c'est ce résultat c'est
cette inadéquation entre le besoin
d'infrastructures qui s'est fait sentir
et sur lesquelles il ya eu beaucoup
d'investissements que ce soit des
investissements des fonds européens ou
et collectivités et peut-être pas assez
sur la formation des jeunes sur
l'accompagnement des jeunes pour que
l'on se retrouve en 2020 dans une
situation où nos jeunes nos jeunes
réunionnais parlent anglais
mais je n'allais n'ont pas peur d'aller
dans les pays étrangers que ce soit en
inde ce soir mais ce cap en afrique du
sud que nos jeunes puissent être
accompagnés lorsqu'ils ont un projet
formation un projet de création
d'entreprise est certes il y a eu
aujourd'hui et c'est bien le révélateur
des choses 250 millions justement vie
dans la formation depuis l'année
dernière mais dans ce domaine on ne fait
pas de choses en un clin d'oeil on ne
fait pas de choses en un coup de
baguette magique il faut du temps il
faut une dizaine d'années pour mettre en
place une politique de formation qui
donne les résultats ou dix ans vous
deviez être
assez satisfait vous l'avez dit que le
le plafond de de décélération soit
rentré dans les secteurs stratégiques
c'était 1,6 à 2,2 m 2 mais c'est déjà un
un geste là encore vous dit bon voilà la
question du chômage
alors la mesure qui avait été prise à
dernière dans le bf de 2018 en 2019 à
l'oeuf à la violence acté qu'on avait
une exonération des charges sociales
pour les entreprises dans les secteurs
stratégiques c'est-à-dire qui bénéficié
de son appel exonérations renforcées
jusqu'à 1,7 smic
il s'est avéré que les entreprises nous
ont dit que c'était plutôt une trappe on
appelle à bas salaires chez les gens et
on essaie de ne pas sauter est passé en
fait 1,7 smic et donc sécurisé des
serres qui était relativement bas alors
j'ai fait à un moment pour le vf2000 20
sur lesquels je proposais que
l'exonération dans les secteurs
stratégiques passe à 2,2 le gouvernement
a sous-amendé à mon sens que je
proposais et et athée en fait que
l'exonération passer pour deux fois
logique c'est à dire ah
à 2-1 puis quoi les deux noms seydoux
comment ça marche sauf que pour des
milliers personnes qui sont venues cette
ça va être l'occasion de demander une
augmentation de 100 200 300 sur le
salaire sans que celui qui les
rémunèrent charges sociales et c'est une
avancée certes qui est avancé de
marchands de tapis mais qui va permettre
d'avoir 100 200 300 pas tout à fait
négligeable on se trouve aujourd'hui et
c'est je vous dis même l'une des
avancées assez importante qui n'a pas
été spécialement mon chevet mais qui
n'avance est assez impressionnante dans
le cadre évidemment les annonces
présidentielles lorsqu'il avait vu
pendant ces trois jours c'est presqu'à
seule nouvelle annonce que c'est la
seule bonne nouvelle il y a eu assez
le boîtier des pecs mais je crois quand
même qu'il faut qu'on élargit cette
mesure et qui n'a pas que dans les
secteurs les citer mais une grande
partie sérieuse
oui ça couvre une grande partie mais
j'espère et j'espérais surtout et
j'avais déposé en ce sens que les
entreprises du bâtiment rentrer dans ce
secteur des exonérations renforcées
il ya quatorze mille emplois on aurait
pu par une seule mesure avoir deux ou
trois mille emplois supplémentaires en
passant en exonération a forcé les
bâtiments c'était tout à fait justifiée
dans la mesure où il y a
conférence logement avec un nouveau plan
logement notamment se dit comment et les
charges sociales serait tout à fait
s'arrêter tout à fait judicieux
évidemment pour le dtp d'abord une
exonération en force et de charges c'est
ce que j'attendais évidemment des
mesures pour le plf 2009 la
pérennisation des parcours emploi
compétences hauteur de 12 me pour les
trois années qui viennent avec ses 4000
en 2016 mardi c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
gaza soit stabilisé comme petite
visibilité difficile de faire autrement
le présent compris pas tout d'un coup
comme ça supprimer l'ensemble des
contrats aidés pour les associations
sportives culturelles dans les mairies
dans les écoles il a reconnu qu'en début
de mandat y avait peut-être pris des
mesures dures que ce soit pour les faits
pour lorsqu'on fait face ici c'est un
territoire et visiblement ils ont des
questions on retire du pouvoir d'achat
aux retraités qui n'ont pas la
possibilité autrement évidemment d'avoir
un salaire lorsqu'on retire l'accession
au logement
et puis qu'on leur met trois ans pressé
que l'on reconnaît quand même l'avoir
fait 9 heures lorsqu'on annonce la fin
des pecs et que lors d'une visite
présidentielle
on ne remet avec mille places
supplémentaires c'est convoqué ben arfa
les erreurs je crois quand même il faut
se demander si ce gouvernement a bien
pris conscience de la situation première
je crois qu'il commence à prendre
conscience à travers ces visites
je crois qu'il faut encore un peu de
temps il faut surtout que les élus se
mettent d'accord pour faire des demandes
cohérente et demande puissante pour
qu'on les obtiennent est-ce que nous
cours de cette visite quand on a vu il
ya eu un peu de mobilisation
des zizou il ya eu une manifestation est
née un mouvement de grève
général c'est par une intersyndicale et
en même temps vous dit le président
prend conscience quand il vient de la
réalité et enfin un petit post il n'y a
pas eu de rencontre que le service les
services d'ordre le service de presse le
service de sécurité autour du trésor et
que finalement c'était un peu
déshumanisé
cette rencontre parcours vous l'avez que
vous l'avez vous avez vous êtes pu
l'approcher
on a on l'a rencontré alors il ya eu
plusieurs temps en réalité dans cette
visite présidentielle un premier temps
qu'il aurait dû normalement se placer à
la fin stratégiquement le temps où il
visite en fait le forum
l'excès qui est un forum digital
transformation digitale de la région
c'est un moment important pour parler
qui s'adressait certes aux entrepreneurs
mais s'adresser au monde entier pour
aulas et aragon sur une carte mais on va
en parler il ya un deuxième temps où il
voulait définir les priorités pour
l'emploi il a appelé sa dinde un terme à
leur pétrole ça ne correspond pas grand
chose en fait c'est une ensemble de
mesures qui complètent ou qu'ils
augmentent en fait ce qui avait déjà été
mise en place
il voulait une troisième temps en fait
faire une rencontre populaire avec la
population à 30 ans il aurait dû le
mettre en premier ça stratégiquement à
la communication c'est ça qu'on met en
premier c'est un moment donné faire ce
que j'ai rien fait alors qu'elle était
venue rencontrer les jeunes à aller voir
la population lui dire qu'est-ce qui m'a
pas mais ça veut dire quelque chose
qu'il n'ait pas fait qui puisse
peut-être pas le fais je crois que comme
en métropole il ya peut-être pour le
président de france ou de réunions la
région crée ici
la réunion qui réussit pas validé la
réunion ce n'est pas la réunion créé ici
la réunion qui s y passe et une seule
réunion ce sont des réunionnais et dans
ces réunionnais il a évidemment les
chances que la chance de réussir et puis
les gens qui attendent évidemment un
coup de main pour pouvoir réussir
donc il n'a pas fait le lien entre les
deux et c'est ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher il va qu'on vous le biais de
sa vie par
ce sommet de choses la réunion une façon
de faire mieux des investisseurs
étrangers mais un discours très tournée
vers la place de la france ces alliances
dans la région et la place de la france
dans ce cet espace indo pacifique
4 nous éclairer un peu ça a du sens cet
espace indo pacifique il va de 2 de
l'afrique à l'amérique en passant par
l'australie président ça va toujours
grand peut-être un peu trop grand
évidemment pour la réunion mais ça a du
sens ce discours a du sens et il ne faut
pas oublier non plus que l'influencé
française dans et jusqu'au pacifique
passe par la région et respectable que
ça passe encore plus pour la réunion et
donc il faut comprendre évidemment ce
discours comme ça quels sont les
domaines qui sont concernés évidemment
lorsqu'il parle de culture du rivage de
fans tchèques c'est le numérique
aujourd'hui qui est concerné avec le
trail à une demande très précises sont
allés plus loin lorsque les acteurs on
rencontre les acteurs ils disent mais il
faut évidemment des investissements à
risque plus important la réunion ont
entraîné ces entreprises il faut par
exemple investissements dans un câble
dédié qui va relier la réunion reste du
monde pour abaisser les coûts
transmission de l'information
c'est le même du développement durable
et de l'environnement il n'est pas allé
prouvé en glorieuse le domaine qui qui
qui dit que à la réunion c'est un
hotspot internationale lorsque son
environnement et que doit on doit
protéger l'ensemble de cet océan
notamment et donc il ya une vision
transnationales qui passe par la région
et qui est assez intéressant est le
troisième axe qui dessine c'est la
mobilité des hommes
comment faire en sorte que les
réunionnais à et plus souvent en inde
plus souvent en afrique du sud ce soir
madagascar et trouve les moyens de leur
expansion dans l'informatique dans
l'environnement ou dans d'autres
domaines
il a tracé un certain nombre d'actes qui
ne sont pas inintéressant mais qui ne
règle pas évidemment les problèmes
quotidiens
mais ce discours est un discours
important parce qu'il va faire là il va
faire là par rapport à nos voisins
mauriciens malgaches africain il y avait
des indiens et les singapouriens et ça
replace la réunion dans une stratégie
dire qui est importante maintenant c'est
aux collectivités se saisir évidemment
de ces opportunités
comment est-ce qu'on mise en oeuvre qui
je vais vous donner quelques exemples là
à la réalisation d'un câble qui va
relier parolier en fait la réunion reste
du monde c'est un outil qui est très
important la capacité que peut avoir la
région accompagné à sa nombre
d'entreprises ou de jeunes startups dans
leur implantation ou dans leurs marchés
en cas de marchés extérieurs ce sont des
outils qui peuvent pousser un jeune
c'est la région qu'il entend donner ses
rayons c'est la région qui est acteur
évidemment de la délégation économique
et donc évidemment c'est la région à
reprendre le relais et je crois que ce
discours était à la transat à
l'intention directement la région il ya
il y avait un sens je vous le dis car
cette intervention il a parlé de
d'éviter les intrusions s'était passé au
pacifique ça veut dire quoi
c'est de cette collaboration sont assez
renforcée y compris militaires et l'inde
ça veut dire quoi concrètement sur le
rôle de la france et de la réunion d'un
point de vue stratégique et géopolitique
ça veut dire que la france un axe
stratégique qui passe par l'inde mais
qui ça passe aussi jusqu'à en fait la
nouvelle zélande et l'australie
cet axe stratégique qui est un axe de
coopération scientifique et militaire
eux aussi évidemment passer par la
réunion passé par madagascar
passé par l'afrique du sud avec un
certain nombre de pays africains et on
voit que le déploiement de ses sacs ses
axes stratégiques se pose en quelque
sorte assez route de la soie chinoise et
on a là le jeu qui le jeu indien choisi
pour la france plutôt évidemment que le
jeu chinois avec ses roues stratégique
ce discours s'adresser au rhénus les
s'adresser plus globalement ou monde
entier et je crois que c'est intéressant
que ce discours était fait à la réunion
à destination des régions à destination
des chefs d'état de la région regret
c'est à la réunion sur la région sur une
feinte la réunion plutôt sur une échelle
mondiale et je vous disais
il faut qu'on se saisisse ces axes
lancée de ses flèches en quelque sorte
lancé pour qu on nous remet perd une
stratégie régionale
est-ce que ça fait comme vous delà de la
région notamment doivent être plutôt un
oeil intéressé sur ces routes de la soie
chinoise et sur la soie caché et ce
qu'il faut qu'on se dise nous réunion
entre l'inde et la chine
je crois qu'il faut qu'on choisisse une
stratégie qui est aussi celle décliné
par la france on ne peut pas avoir des
stratégies régionales qui se dit
scandalisé par d'accord stratégie
française
il ya une nécessité à sonnettes et s
accorder évidemment nos instruments pour
la musique parce que la france c'est la
réunion dans la france ce n'est pas la
réunion indépendante de la france
concrètement ça veut dire que vous en
tant que la région pour un prix encore
le relais ou est ce que doit être que
c'est pas rien dire là jours paris
savent associer la région concernée je
l'aï dit il faut aller dans ce sens
c'est ça l'idée je pense que ce discours
fondateur d'une nouvelle ère d'une
politique régionale qui va plus loin que
les seuls pays voisins agrément de la
région la politique régionale en
destination de l'inde est une politique
aussi important sur le plan des séances
et sur le plan de l'armement sur le plan
des échanges avec un erasmus wii tels
que le président disait les échanges
avec l'afrique du sud où avec les pays
africains qui vont plus loin que les
seuls bill haas et oui il faut pas
oublier que cette stratégie s'adresse
aussi à la réunion parce que la france
va être avoir le secret à général la
série ont donné deux heures et donc
qu'il ya là c'est oui se saisissent
évidemment de ces problématiques pour
pour décliner ces axes au niveau là
c'est oui d'ailleurs vous avez bossé
avec
les autres députés riou dans quel sens
l'agriculture et la production locale
agricole est ce que vous avez été
entendu sous avait 106 voir passer
visite présidentielle que ce que vous
avez porté comme comme comme demande sur
les possibilités d'exporter des fruits
légumes sur les aides sont des filières
locales
vous avez très attendu alors d'abord
j'ai écouté avant de faire cette
proposition de loi qui est qui émane des
acteurs locaux notamment de la dire même
s'il a ses pme et des filières agricoles
et qui nous ont dit comme aux autres
nous n'avons pas assez de reconnaissance
de nos produits fabriqués localement les
pros du pays
il faut absolument que les collectivités
d'une part achètent plus de production
locale c'est la garantie plus d'emplois
mais il faut aussi s'est fait en sorte
que dans les grandes surfaces
nos produits soient mieux reconnus plus
reconnus et donc il ya eu une
déclinaison des propositions qui ont été
faites notamment par la dir c'est cet
ensemble qui a été repris dans cette
proposition de loi j'ai déposé donc à
l'assemblée nationale pour permettre à
les produits péi logo d'être plus
visible d'être mieux valorisé sur des
rayons dans les grandes surfaces qui se
décline en cinq articles avec la
proposition clope et mer soit un peu le
vérificateur de cette bonne place de la
production locale sur le marché fait en
sorte qu'au moins 30 %
l'ensemble des rayons et qu'ils soient
elles on trouve évidemment les produits
locaux et qui est un certain nombre des
processus qui qui évite des cartes et
notamment près des panneaux logistique
d'écarter les produits locaux
cette proposition a été déposée je vais
évidemment envoyé au premier son
président et au ministère de l'outre-mer
j'ai le sentiment que ce qui a été dit
notamment lors du passage du président
république c'est un peu la défense de la
production locale
alors évidemment les acteurs lui ont
répété roddy la production locale c'est
plus emploi c'est la qualité s'est dit
choqué cours c'est la garantie que notre
économie
et notre développement se fait de
manière endogène c'est à dire à la
réunion avec des entreprises
réunionnaises avec des jeunes rennais je
crois que le moment fort où il a dit ça
c'est lors de sa conférence de presse
notamment face au monde agricole
à 20 ans je crois ce discours là était
entendue sincèrement savent bien que
c'est finalement david oreo et lu les
républicains qui avaient finalement les
côtes du président de la république et
deux de l'appareil le gouvernement
actuellement il n'y a pas d'autres
relais de la république a par exemple
annoncé c'est vous qui faites ce travail
à remonter les revendications de me dire
ça j'ai pas du tout le sentiment que je
sois le plus écouté ou le mieux écouter
simplement il faut éviter d'avoir la
critique pour la critique vaut éviter
d'attaquer pour se faire plaisir surtout
dans cette période électorale où
certains n'y voient qu'un ou des élus
tout simplement surf plus le taux sont
les contraintes la population tire à
boulet rouge évidemment sur un
gouvernement je dis moi je ne suis pas
élu en marche mais il faut avancer il
faut trouver des propositions pour les
jeunes rénové pour les entreprises
l'idée évidemment ce n'est pas être que
dans la critique et certains élus ont
déjà été en responsabilité je puis dire
à tous les élus qui ont déjà été
responsabilité qui ont déjà été maire
qui ont déjà été député qui ont déjà été
la majorité parfois il faut un peu
d'humilité et parfois il faut un peu de
bon sens est de savoir quelles choses ne
vont pas là
ne vont pas d'un coup de baguette
magique il faut un peu tort et un peu de
travail pour quelque chose alors
évidemment il sujet on attendait
quelques quelques réponses le sujet un
peu d'actualité c'était les inquiétudes
par rapport au rachat de vendémian sur
le la baisse des prix chose comme ça
finalement
le président dit vous inquiétez pas
conférence par elisa ou mais on n'en
sait pas beaucoup plus sûrs comme moi
sauf met en place les conditions de
cette concurrence existe assez book
sociaux malheureusement il n'y avait pas
de miracle à attendre le président
n'avait pas réglé non plus la vente dans
un secteur privé d'un opérateur
et par rapport à un autre l'autorité de
la concurrence doit venir sur place
c'est toute la confiance doit regarder
s'il aura bien une concurrence entre
tous les groupes locaux concerne j'ai
dénoncé comme avec l'ensemble des autres
députés sur l'effectif est vigilant on
n'est pas non au vol il faut être
vigilant il n'est pas d'entente
s'il n'est pas très bonne chose il faut
être vigilant que les taxes ne soit pas
trop lourd pour faire augmenter les prix
notre rôle à nous ce brassard à être
vigilant pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'entente notamment et jolie qui est
déjà eu des enfants qui ont été
dénoncées vision pour qu'il ait pas de
monopole
je n'ai pas la sensation qu'il monopole
même après rachat du groupe des biens
par gbh dans l'alimentaire et géant pour
que les taxes qu'on applique évidemment
ne soit pas trop important
je pensais qu'il allait annoncer une
sorte de modifications un petit peu des
détails concernant la tva l'outre-mer ce
n'est pas été le cas
vous auriez souhaité qu'on réfléchisse
sur l'impôt
le maire il faudrait viser pour rien
voilà je pense que s'il faut le faire il
faut le faire à travers une grande
programme qui en même temps on donne la
possibilité à des entreprises locales
d'être rassurés sur le différentiel des
taux concernant l'outre-mer
il a été question aussi de continuité
territoriale avec le même discours c'est
évidemment vous inquiétez pas la
concurrence va faire baisser les prix
est ce que quand tu la situation qu'on
connaît du territoire réunionnais avec
les oignons avec la petitesse du marché
c'est un peu comme l'a fait pressante
bien vous inquiétez pas c'est la
concurrence qui va vous permettre à des
prix bas on sera la continuité
territoriale
je crois qu'il faut faire attention
surtout quand on parle de continuité
territoriale
elle est nécessaire elle doit être
encore plus importante
lorsqu'il y a un besoin les placements
entre la réunion et la métropole
lorsque les jeunes on use and soul est
passé lorsque les malades ont passé
lorsqu'il ya une recherche d'emploi
lorsqu'une recherche de formation et là
il faut pas être petit il faut
accompagner toute sa demande légitime de
via et le mobilité entre l'europe et la
réunion et ça nécessite des fonds qui
sont relativement importants et je le
dis à l'état l'état doit être présente
dans cette mobilité pour tous ceux qui
sont à la recherche de formation et
d'emploi
la mobilité qui consiste juste à aller
en vacances en europe ou métropole est
une mobilité qui aujourd'hui supporté
entièrement par agent je crois qu'il
faudrait au péché ces fonds à mon sens
en tout cas vers une mobilité plus utile
je ne dis pas que parti en vacances est
pas utile mais la mesure où on manque de
fonds il faudrait repêchées ces vont
faire une unité mobilité qui me
semblerait plus utile aux jeux mais
aussi regarder le bien et que les
offenses parti travailler le bois avec
la famille aussi un lien fort entre
unique qui a vite retrouvé était bien
sûr je n'ai pas il faut qu'elles
disparaissent mais je dis qu'il faut que
les trous soit très variables entre ceux
qui en ont vraiment besoin
et ceux qui partent en vacances l'agent
de retraite en cours de discussion mon
dossier compliqué dans ces mobilisations
sociales vous pensez que le plan vers
lequel va le gouvernement ça vous va
dans le bon sens et vous fait cette
démarche
cette réforme est une réforme qui va
être très très complexe pour le
gouvernant parce que changer 43 régimes
spéciaux avec des régimes qui sont tout
à fait différent entre eux on a bien vu
les avocats les médecins les policiers
ou les militaires qu'elles ont tous
j'aime très différents et sur lequel il
ya une histoire cherchent chacun des
régimes
je crois qu'aucun noir est assez
ambitieux pouvoir changer il va y avoir
des blocages de notre économie si vous
vraiment on veut aller trop vite
il faut être attentif aux réunionnais en
particulier ce coup dur il faut être
attentif à la situation n est ce pas ce
que cette situation est une situation
très particulière où on a une fonction
publique sur lesquels il ya parfois des
difficultés jeu juste avant de dire je
recevais un coup de fil notamment des
facteurs de dessin 9 qui me disait il y
à des réformes qui sont en cours et pour
nous c'est un bon sable de pouvoir cet
essai réforme telle qu'elle ne les
proposent il faut du temps pour faire
des choses il faut la discussion est le
principal reproche je peux faire au
président aby gouvernants quelquefois
c'est le temps de la discussion
le temps du compromis le temps du
dialogue au faire aboutir des dossiers
pour qu'ils soient plus consensuel on a
vu dans l'alabama où la loi bioéthique
c'est insensé j'avais voté contre j'ai
voté pour l'article images et conquis
contre la loi parce qu'elle était trop
rapide certains d'entre nous n'ont pas
eu le temps de lire la totalité de la
loi selon eux aussi important qui
concerne l'homme et la femme sans les
enfants faut prendre le temps en deux
temps la discussion entre les personnes
évidemment qui sont responsables ce
n'est pas un coup de cuillère à pot de
manifestations et puis un vote à 4
heures du matin qu'on peut aujourd'hui
prendre de telles lois en lice en autant
de monde
évidemment sans expression vous avez
voté la loi sur l'impossibilité de du
recours à la pma pour les femmes seules
et les couples homosexuels nous écoutent
et contre l'ensemble vous avez un
rapport le chu la région aussi aux
antilles aura pas de revalorisation
cessa de la présence de deux des
surcoûts il ya les oignons nous est axée
sur ce dossier les rues alors j'ai
présenté un dossier effectivement et ça
va qu'il présenta les questions de
première on a défendu ce dossier avec
acharnement de 20 des questions devant
évidemment les ministres et avec la page
dans la semaine évidemment à rodez fondu
les amendements l'hémicycle faire
comprendre que le coefficient
géographique pas selon l'hôpital mais
aussi dans tous les secteurs médico
sociaux doit être relevé si on ne veut
pas un chu et et des établissements
constamment en déficit
et lorsque ces établissements son
déficit ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que la pression pèse évidemment
sur tous les salariés surtout les
employés leur demande de faire des
efforts de diminution de personnel le
dhimmi chantant d'activités parfois de
disparition de certaines filières et
donc il est nécessaire aujourd'hui parce
que ça n'a pas été revalorisée qu'on
revalorise le coefficient géographique
pour passer de 1 35 c à 35% de coûts en
plus lorsque c'est nécessaire je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce gouvernement est
sourd à sa demande qui émane de la
totalité des députés d'ailleurs aussi
bien des antilles qu'à la réunion
je crois qu'on va mettre en danger en
péril à la santé des réunionnais
certains domaines sont catastrophiques à
santé mentale par exemple on est
d'emblée difficile chronique à nyon on
est bien plus maltraitées évidemment
qu'en métropole
il ya nécessité le président n'a pas
parlé mais nécessité de revoir
évidemment le budget d
je suis a rien là de police locale la
droite reste est elle toujours aussi
divisée à l'approché des municipales il
ya des hommes et il ya forcément des
partis politiques le parti républicain
un nouveau chef christian jacob il ya
les adhérents les républicains il ya un
président de fédération qui est michel
fontaine le parti politique va émettre
un certain nombre d'idées discuter avec
les uns ou les autres va revoir sa ligne
politique
je suis ceux qui souhaitent évidemment
un homme politique soit revue et que
dans ce parti politique les outre-mer
est tout sauf une en quel sens c'est à
dire que vous n'étiez pas croire que les
nouveaux qui je trouve est évidemment
qu'elle était trop dure et qu il l était
pas assez évidemment conciliante avec à
l'ensemble des minorités avec une
politique migratoire avec les politiques
sociales ou les services sociaux donc
j'avais quelques quelques différences
mais qui mangeait pas évidemment de
soutenir le parti politique des
républicains
il a pris la société aussi tout revient
voilà il c'est à dire capable de bien
personne de qui pouvait prendre cette
responsabilité pour la santé non il me
l'a proposé et je lui dis que je ne
pouvais pas moi tout faire et qu'il y
avait des situations qui était compliqué
à la réunion comme aux antilles et qu'il
est nécessaire que lui d'abord se
fassent connaître en outre-mer qu'il a
il faut qu'il ne se présente et qu'il
dise clic évidemment qu'est ce que c'est
nécessaire c'est sûr parce qu'il ya un
chef michel fontaine les républicains
didier ouvert je pas éluder la question
didier robert que le présent des régions
et n'est plus chez les républicains il
est à objectif réunion s qu'objectif
rennais on est un parti de droite
est-ce que j'ai été freiné en suit le
gouvernement est-ce qu'il a sa propre
tactique la question c'est ça et c'est
ce que
voir divisés avec des objets qui font
d'un côté et de l'autre payer section je
crois que si on envisage choses comme ça
on va évidemment perdre beaucoup
d'électeurs moi je suis de ceux qui
nécessairement ni il faut un
rapprochement il faut se mettre d'accord
sur un certain nombre de décisions qui
sont décision très contractuels et le
printemps il ya une discussion à voir
michel fontaine isère d'autres doit
discuter ensemble a présenté bien peu de
jours selon l'agencé puis il ya surtout
concurrence par rapport à tous les tous
les militants et tous les gens de droite
qui nous regarde et qui se disent a
demandé qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire pourquoi pourquoi s'est-elle
animosité c'est ellen parce que il ya
une situation rennaise qui est très
difficile et ces petits combats chef
nous intéresse pas plus que ça il est en
cours suite à des soupçons de bourrages
d'urnes à saint-pierre sabres en
conséquence être 4e leveaux qui
vomissent y voit là ça va laisser faire
la justice mais tout à fait sincèrement
dans une élection européenne avait aucun
enjeu puisqu'on avait nous aucun
représentant réunionnais sur la lys
c'est bien que la liste de vos séries à
fait normal
évidemment de la position à l'ère michel
fontaine je pense que maintenant il faut
aller trop vite et laisser la justice
faire je suis à peu près sûr que
quelques surprises
c'est à dire quel jour de surprises vous
attendent à linverse ce que nous a dans
ses attentes
une petite minute
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
ligne de mire va peut être évoluer avec
de christine la question du voile
revient dans l'espace public
en quelques mots ou est ce que est ce
que c est ce qu il faut l'avoir est-ce
que c'est faire le jeu du front national
on est sur une île où il ya évidemment
plusieurs influences ses cultures et
plusieurs religions
chacun peut s'habiller comme ils le
souhaitent dans la rue dans les espaces
ouverts au public
chez lui en partant à la messe autre
emploi la mosquée moi je suis pour cette
grande liberté chacun évidemment il se
disposer les avis qui lui conviennent le
mieux
après je suis sur la position du
président la république lorsqu'on est à
l'école lorsqu'on est dans un
établissement public d'enseignement
lorsqu'on exerce des activités qui sont
les activités avec les enfants
je crois qu'il faut se tenir à une
grande laïcité et au fait que la
religion ne rentre pas dans ces espaces
merci merci beaucoup avec le registre
d'avoir été notre invité sur rayon la
première passé et toujours merci à tout
le monde qui nous a coûté
la première
[Musique]
embarquez pour un voyage auditifs unique
sauvage et hypnotique aux frontières de
l'antarctique composé par julien
gauthier lors de son séjour aux
kerguelen une symphonie mise en
mouvement par 35 musiciens de l
orchestre de la région réunion samedi de
novembre à 20 heures à saint gilles plus
d'informations au www.cancer.ca région
reunion.com il fait plaise y avoir à
vous préparer un bon quart